hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the last stand Union City
now this is the final game in the last
stand series but it's totally different
from the other games that you've seen
before it involves an entirely different
shift in everything that's been going on
in this game it doesn't involve the
standing and shooting mechanic I've
actually played this one before it
involves exploring the entirety of Union
City and scavenging in real time you
don't just a set it a sign so it's
almost a completely different game so my
name is Mark EMU Mick [ __ ] and I'm
male I'm from wherever the hell that is
with that big-ass zip code
I am Haney meanie miney moe
eenie meenie miney mo any meaning any
any Metheny enemy me alright we're going
for it and I am someone I'm an engineer
I could have been an engineer and in my
mind I could have been an engineer in my
line of work but in this regard this is
what is so in this game and I'm kind of
foggy about the details of exactly what
happened in this game but it's kind of
the early onset of the zombie outbreak
so it's not necessarily hey that's yours
well if that was pretty Instant Karma I
guess I had that coming for me because
I'm an [ __ ] that looks at my phone
while I'm driving okay but I'm still
alive argh damn it oh gotta get home
what the hell did I hear oh oh sweet
lord e okay so anyway so this is what I
meant whoa is that even human well it's
got arms like a human and legs like a
human and a face kind of like a human
but I can't be too sure about anything
oh god why I killed someone because of
my irresponsible texting and draw
Bing okay so this is how the game works
you search through different places and
you find items and you carry them and
you put them in your inventory it's
actually really detailed it's totally
cool and I've never beaten the game I
have no idea how to get to the end of
the game and frankly I don't even know
what I'm supposed to be doing but you
can have your gun Stav body armour a
bunch of equipment on this guy with this
nice fro I'd like to think I'm Wade if
Wade didn't choose to do YouTube he
would have gone on to be an engineer
maybe I don't barely know but I don't
think I could check anything else here
anyway so now we go to the next area and
I've got my handy little gun here and IV
what the hell is going on oh god no way
whoa hey whoa back up there you were a
lot quicker than I thought you'd be bunk
okay so this is good and I'm actually
playing on survival mode which means
that there's some extras whoa hey stop
that
good thing I'm not gonna be infected by
you I've got space shoves enemies
sorry just wanted to thrust into my
groin a little bit I do my victory
thrusts after I beat my zombies yeah
yeah you like that you want it okay
anyway I'm gonna move on thunk whoa nice
critical hit on that one yeah oh sorry
forgot to do my victory thrusts I'm just
gonna hustle my way out of here
I'll make sure the next town eventually
don't mind me I'm just really happy
about killing zombo's okay anyway
killing zombo's with my epic combos
anybody home oh you you want some hmm
you want some of this
probably not ow ow you got a lot of
reach I don't like that I'm trying to
get by without the reach and everyone's
grabbing all over me okay don't need
that but I might need the wood board
I don't remember than it there I don't
know if there's any sort of crafting
here but there's definitely survival
stuff in terms of food because I am
playing aah holy God okay
empty not quite empty it's filled with
zombo's I guess I guess I'm looking for
human companionship not necessarily the
companionship of horrifying zombies but
Lisa this one out and you can I believe
you can actually find survivors much
like in the other Last Stand games you
can find survivors and this looks like a
safe house hello hi how are you Jackson
I'm sorry I just moved in with you one
of the neighbors I guess that doesn't
matter now you're safe here
this all started a few days ago people
just started killing each other the ones
they killed didn't stay dead stay here
and rest up I've got Sarah
who the hell is Sarah Oh know who there
oh there's more I've got Sarah and Peter
now for next door staying in my room
upstairs you're welcome to sleep on the
floor in here if you need okay don't
check if I'm bit or anything I'm just
gonna I'm gonna hostel look at my skills
I'm a contributing member of society
with my epic dance moves okay so I'm
gonna I don't think there's gonna be
anything else up here but there's other
people upstairs who might might might
have something for me to do I can't
remember if there's kind of quest system
in this game hello oh you're not one of
them thank God huh I was wondering why
Jackson would have let one of them I'd
be here
Jackson was kind enough to take us in he
secured the place as best he could I
don't think they're getting in here
anytime soon my husband was lost it he
wants to leave I think it's best we stay
here and witnessing out right anyway
good luck finding your way oh god we're
dead do my epic hustle thrusts help no
see oh god oh god oh god why won't they
stop why this is happening they are two
kids what do they want from me we have
to leave we have to leave the bags are
packed and ready we can go we can go now
how about you don't how about you stay
where it's kind of safe ooh
long red shirt okay that way my enemies
won't see me bleed about some of that
point much better I'm looking like a
little ll I'm the guy from the Last of
Us who's Joel Joel I'm looking like Joel
more and more every day oh thank god
I'm leaving you don't have to be so
cruel I'm gonna use the bin
I'm gonna I'm gonna sleep for just four
hours here just to get my health back up
and maybe get into the day
nope it's in the middle of the night I'm
sure it'll be even better to go out
hello are you my friend
Oh God which they're too quick too quick
at least I reached level two also
there's a leveling up component I
totally forgot about that okay so what
I'm gonna get is I'm gonna get luck I'm
just gonna do nothing but luck and I'm
gonna actually up my blades because I
don't think I have enough of that unless
I want to get something else ah
searching nice I want to get searching
up because I'm just gonna be lucky and
really get it searching and have
absolutely no survivor skills which is
exactly what I need oh look it's nice I
don't even know if cash is worth
anything not in this world anyway okay I
got my gun you'll see nothing there
nothing there that's nice okay
did anybody in here just make sure that
I'm actually full up on him I was not
full up on animal I was actually
completely out okay I believe that I
actually do need to eat stuff so I'm
gonna get this orange honey yeah okay
chocolate okay there we go
and I should be fine okay that'll be
good enough for now and then I'll get
this possum an egg beater I don't need
an egg beater why could I even carry an
egg beater with me that seems like a
horrible thing to actually take with ya
but I got that dishwashing liquid I
could drink that and desperation hello
okay now I'm paid out and oh man that
was actually pretty cool okay who I
don't know how to do this
I don't know how to do this I'm not
Humber said sure
press and hold the pushpin up watch and
listen for the pin to pass over the
sweet spot hold the key longer to push
the pin higher lock all the pins in the
sweet spot to complete the pic forcing a
lock open is risky the percent shown is
your chance of success if you fail the
you will break the lock turn on 4 is it
hey I'm lucky I got it open holy crap
that means I have an undamaged taran I
don't know if that's better it is better
okay this is good
okay so unequip that let's see take that
out put that in and then I can probably
just drop the other stuff or maybe sell
them if I ever get to a point where I
could do that need to reload should be
loaded whoa that worked out delightfully
and this pile of ammo here yes things
are going wonderfully for me I wonder
when they're gonna get bad I mean I'm
going to go farther into the city
eventually it's just that right now I
want to make sure ball baseball bat
that's probably that's probably really
good okay I can have that as my other
weapon because sounds like it might be
better than a tire iron yeah okay good
perfect I've got plenty of ammo and I've
actually got a little bit of food which
is halfway decent and man I'm whoa hey
whoa hey oh ha ha how's it going there
alright shirt blue don't eat bad I want
my Joel shirt anything in your pain
pills that'll do good ha now it's time
to actually going to the city stop
wandering around the fellow houses here
and I should go deep into the city where
I need to get back home where I'm
assuming that I have a family or maybe
not I don't know I'm probably very low
need to get home to Beth that's right
Mike ha ha ha oh that's what you get
whoa hello how's it going there buddy
how you doing can I talk to you okay how
about Edie the military put this fence
up a few days ago blocking the road to
Brookvale then abandoned it we need
something to cut our way through I know
ray and number 12 is a pair of bolt
cutters I borrowed them last month ok
number 12 it is wasn't I just Oh
hello don't mind me she's gonna come up
with my Louisville Slugger that wasn't
me
no no yeah yeah okay number 12 it's the
only one I didn't go to Hey
oink beep didn't see nothing
you didn't see me you didn't see nothing
all right extended mag not bad in cash
see I told you that luck in searching
we're gonna do me good where to put my
gun you think you would need that ray
what's that that bastard ed sent you old
cutters he borrowed them weeks ago and
never returned them the probably next
door it is stinging garage go tell him
that he's still got the damn things oh
by the way your house is infested with
tons of zombo's you might want to take
care of that maybe I should give you a
gun but I'm not nice enough to do that
because your do seem like kind of a dick
whoa hey ho hey come on now don't be
like that
be nice be nice I should be a little
more genteel about things that I do here
because otherwise I'm just going to end
up with absolutely no health and no way
to recover it before now we're okay open
a call claw hammer not not good okay
actually was that good mm I like my bat
it has some knock-back pretty decent
okay so in his garage here that he I
need to talk to him first he has it
already huh I have them maybe I didn't
return them here's a key to my garage go
400 michelle phan bring it back okay
thank you
I got a garage key and I'm level three
why stop that I wasn't ready
trying to do something here but they
didn't level up okay I'm just gonna keep
going on the searching because hot damn
that's doing me some good all right so
leveled up I'm switching to the gun whoa
[ __ ] me Jesus oh my god what the [ __ ]
is it over whoa my god that honestly
scared me
I wasn't ready okay then all right okay
down you go that was fun I didn't know
that could do that oh man okay
flashlight I don't think I'm on the
right way to go to the place where I
need to go nothing in here ice a shirt
in a kitchen cabinet why is there a
kitchen upstairs doesn't make any sense
boy oh hey come on come on now how about
you hit him okay you stay nice and slow
there we go
man this targeting reticle is not okay
all right I got pistols I got enough
pistols I don't need any more pistols
I've got that 9-millimeter extended mag
that I might want to try because that
could like a few more bullets than five
would be awfully nice see let me do that
right now because I can think about that
yeah extended mag does eight damage oh
no I like what I got going on right now
okay
just check this okay full up on ammo
let's do this cuz this is more damage
per bullet which means a lil oh nice
shotgun oh yeah
Oh teddy sprinkles I like the sound of
that
but I only got 25 shotgun shells so I'm
gonna stick with what I got so far I'm
just gonna trash these I don't need
these and I have no option to sell them
just yet so I'm gonna try the pistol
just to try because I can't remember
ATS more accurate that's the thing okay
crowbar bag of nails I don't need the
crowbar crowbars too heavy crowbar is
good though
I will admit crowbar versus the baseball
bat yeah okay ha but the crowbars heavy
the baseball that's really light I'm
gonna stay with that golf called bill
man okay it's got a lot of reach I bet
though old cutters got it okay we got
what we needed we're gonna move out
nobody try to stop me I'm too pro hello
stop pointing that gun at me
yeah or I'm gonna do something last year
you are not yeah yeah you like that okay
did you find those bolt cutters here
they are and them over we can make our
way okay cool got a new area sweet I
don't even know if I ever made it this
far
kinda was just dancing around the main
area and died way too quickly probably
okay go into Tanner Street all right
it's just the next block over maybe you
never know it's gonna be standing in our
way all right I'm gonna get over there
Oh yep kill Oh you're tougher curb your
wait up
oh my god tough okay that hurt a little
bit okay I switch to the gunner forget
that I was an ammo yeah miss good job
missing that's these are definitely
tougher than the other ones
OOP but I got stuff cash I'm not gonna
go in the house is just yet I'm gonna
explore to the end of the street to see
where I'm going and then it's probably
circled back I probably need to go into
that area okay just one block over I
mean he said oh that's a safe house in
there
okay I'm gonna rest up for a second
anyway ooh sawed-off shotgun hell yeah
okay cookies breakfast cereal okay I can
rest up grab some ammo and eat do what I
need to okay then sleep for four hours
and I'm good
hopefully my wife was still alive when I
get there or girlfriend I honestly don't
know it may be one or the other and then
I'll get some food
where's my food can I read this whoa I
can't read that
ah don't need an eggbeater don't need a
football why do I have a bag of nails
unless I'm gonna be crafting okay got
that breakfast your breakfast yes okay
I'm good
all right now we can face the day
hopefully not die okay here we go I'm
going to an apartment I don't even have
a house gosh horrible life do I live
home
god I hope Bethany's is this a is this a
home is this it Beth
Bethany oh that ain't good
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
No woof
okay that was difficult skill to known
oh man this is I probably should have
gone into those places because right now
I don't seem to be doing a hundred
percent okay skill to low skill to low
security scoop oh she's not here maybe
she left a note okay that's probably
good clue somewhere in here
none of that suit jacket though that ooh
I can look badass see what is that mark
EMU oh I've gone to the hospital to help
out where I can come meet me there love
Beth the hospital that place is gonna be
a mess
poor on that sounds nice nosy okay I'll
take that I don't know what the tour on
does loo pain pills good for me
okay nothing else seems to be around
here man okay goodbye whoo that's
problematic
okay huh sorry I knocked you right down
to the floor didn't mean to do that okay
Oh get the thing on the wall get the
Mark Twain over there there's a lot of
stuff left to explore man but I gotta
all go all the way to the inner city
Hospital there's a lot of stuff in this
game that's the amazing thing about this
game there is a lot of content and I
would love I would love to explore it
all and yet I can't fit it all into a
single video let's play because I don't
know if I want to do a series on this
game because I kind of want you guys to
be able to play for yourself this game
is ludicrously fun because there's just
so much to it there's there's just a lot
to it there's a lot to explore there's a
lot to do there's a lot to see there's a
lot to risk there's a lot to play that
like there's a lot of dynamic to it and
it's a simple flash game but in that
it's really really really well put
together it is really well done I like
it a lot it's a phenomenal game you guys
can play it for yourself there's a link
in the description below and if you want
okay if you guys want to see me play
more of this oh they're gone where the
hell do they go you can let me know down
in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching I may
pick it up again I may pick this up
again I don't know if I'm gonna do a
full let's play of it it's very late or
else I would play like a long episode of
it but maybe I can finish it all up in
one episode down the road let me know
what you think in the comment below and
thank you everybody for watching and as
always I will see you
in the next video
what does slack where'd you go from holy
[ __ ] what get off of me what am I
supposed to do come on e on all this not
good oh god what am I done what did I do
to deserve this
it's a good shoe I do I'm gonna die oh
my god hi everybody oh-oh-oh
bye